[Music]
welcome everybody thank you for coming
today
glad to see a nearly full room my name
is Tim I am one of the tech leaves on
the kubernetes project my name is
Michael Rubin I'm a tech lead and
manager in kubernetes also we are here
today to talk to you about networking in
kubernetes specifically in Google cloud
I hope that by the end of today you'll
all realize that this is not nearly as
scary or complicated as it sounds or
maybe I'm wrong so let's start the the
point of kubernetes is to run clusters
right a cluster is natively a network to
construct it is fundamentally about
machines that talk to each other because
of that we have to take networking
really seriously from the very beginning
you can't think about you can't
comprehend community is what we're doing
without really understanding the network
it's really easy to get overwhelmed when
we talk about kubernetes there's a lot
of new terms
everybody here is probably familiar with
basic tcp/ip networking we're going to
build on that knowledge but there's a
lot of new concepts that we need to
bring in things like namespaces and
virtual interfaces and forwarding and IP
tables we are going to demystify that
today for you I hope so
we don't really have a lot of time to do
a kubernetes 101 today so if you're if
you want to talk about how communities
works in the basic constructs I'm happy
to talk to people afterwards or you can
find us on github talk to me on email
but I do want to run through a couple of
background topics that we're going to
touch on today during our talk because I
think it's important that everybody
understands these basics when we talk
about these words so the first term
introduces our API server kubernetes is
a very API centric system the API server
is the center of our universe everything
in our system talks to the API server
our API is a REST API the RN rest is for
resource so we tend to talk about our
API concepts in terms of resources or
objects they mean the same thing it's
really just a serialized blob of data
that we store on our server that
represents a concept in our system so
API server is at the center of
everything
the second concept I want introduce is a
pod hopefully if you know kubernetes you
know what a pod is it is a very little
tiny vm like thing that runs your
containers it is a group of containers
that we schedule together it is the atom
of kubernetes when the containers in a
pod
start and stop the pod still exists when
you delete the pod all the containers go
away together the interesting part here
is one of the fundamental pieces of a
pod is the network everything inside of
a pod shares a network they all see each
other as localhost
they are the same IP address right this
is really important the next concept to
introduce controller so controller is
fundamentally how kubernetes is built it
is basically just a piece of code that
runs in a loop that watches our API
server and responds to changes
right so for example when you create a
pod you want to schedule something in
our system the scheduler wakes up the
scheduler is a controller the scheduler
makes a decision about where it's going
to put the pod it writes something back
to the API server the cubelet wakes up
the cubelet is a controller these are a
fundamental concept that we are going to
build on over and over throughout this
talk the main job of a controller is to
man to make the reality match the intent
you declare what you want it to do and
we're going to make it happen so a label
our API is full of these resources these
objects a label is a tiny little piece
of metadata string to string mapping key
value that you can attach to any one of
our API servers and you can attach any
number of these things to our API
objects these are used for you to group
things however you want to group them we
cannot possibly predict how people are
going to want to use to group to slice
and dice our API so we provided a really
generic mechanism here this is
fundamentally the only grouping
construct in kubernetes we're going to
build on this when we talk about
services and we talked about endpoints
similar to labels is something called
annotations an annotation is the same
structure but unlike a label which we
tend to use for identification
and we tend to use annotation for
third-party pieces to carry extra
information about an object so the
counterpart to labels is selectors a
label declares what something is a
selector declares how you're going to
use the thing right so if you're a
sequel head think of it as select pods
where some condition this gives us a
really loose coupling between concepts
in our system it means that you as a
user can manage groups however you want
to manage them however you want to slice
and dice them for example things with it
used selectors or services deployments
replica sets so a quick example of a
selector so imagine I've got my my
application here running I've got
they're all part of my store but I've
got some front ends and I've got some
back ends and I've got some production
services and I've got some test services
so I can select with a very simple
selector all of my store pods that are
part of the front-end but I could also
select all of my store pods that are
part of my testing right so you can see
here how I can select it any way I want
now I could add another label and I
could add another dimension of selection
right and you can do this arbitrarily
however you need to do to manage your
applications so similarly I could just
select the whole thing so let's talk
about the IP per pod model as Tim said
earlier that every pod is going to have
its own IP address there's a lot of
different ways to do networking in with
respect to containers docker choses vues
you know you know we don't choose to use
a lot of complexity we want to rely on
kubernetes on a lot of old concepts and
traditional ideas involving routing and
networking
there's no machine private IP port
mapping every pod has an IP address and
successful to all the other pods just
like every virtual machine or real
machine as an IP address and it's
easiest when it's accessible to all of
the other and network entities that
you've got in your in your network we're
going to be using in kubernetes are
going to show you how this works
Linux network namespaces and virtual
interfaces in order to implement the
schema so here the VM represented with a
box most computer diagrams are boxes
when you see another box the VM is going
to have a Ethernet device ec 0
and this is normally how you think of
network traffic coming in and out of
your machine now in truth there's this
root namespace network namespace that we
associate with the ethernet device for
linux and this has settings for tcp/ip
stack perhaps other data structures
associated with the linux kernel that
are the context and environment for your
network environment on the virtual
machine what we want to do is have a pod
with its own environment to give it the
illusion that it's living inside its own
space and that you know it's on its own
machine so we create a network name
space for that pod the first pod so
we're going to label it the really
imaginative name pod one now we have a
virtual machine with two environments
that you can run your application in
each one believing that they're inside
their own network namespace problem here
is networks are useful when they can
talk to each other right now
these can't here we can bring up the
idea of a virtual Ethernet device for
Linux it's really just a pipe pair data
will come in one side and come out the
other we want these two 19 spaces to
talk to each other so we take the pipe
pair and using again some basic Linux
tools we can have the pipe pair span
namespaces inside the root namespace we
can give it any name we want and we'll
call it virtual Ethernet devices X X and
inside the pod one we give it a zero so
it looks like it's inside its own
virtual machine we can do this as many
times as we want here we have two pods
on the same virtual machine each one
believing that they're running inside
their own context and they're talking to
the root namespace this is a step
forward but we really want them to talk
to each other so we introduced the
concept of a bridge the bridge is again
something that you've been using a
networking for decades l2 level routing
generally using the ARP protocol I hope
that most of you are familiar with this
it's pretty old standard stuff you can
google it and find out a lot some tools
associated with it today
so let's take a look now at traffic
moving from pod to pod inside the same
node pod one wants to send a message to
pod two so it has an IP packet source IP
is pod one and it's going to do it
leaves the pod ones that were named
space goes through the pipe pair hits
the virtual Ethernet device gets into
the root namespace and goes to the
bridge uses all the ARP logic and
technology to find the right virtual
Ethernet destination and then once it
gets to the top of its pipe pair goes
right through the pipe pair and ends up
in pod twos namespace it's pretty
straightforward pretty simple and using
basic concepts that if they're familiar
with just rudimentary of networking
should feel familiar to you
so pods have to be reachable across VMs
also not just inside of one vm
kubernetes itself doesn't care how you
do this you can use l2 l3 overlay
carrying pigeons unicorns matter but
there has to be some standard way to do
this stuff every VM is given an IP block
and every pot is given an IP address
inside that block so we one thing we
have to do for Google container engine
is teach the network how to route
packets in between VMs so luckily we
have Tim here he knows all about this
stuff
and he's going to show us so building on
the image that we looked at before these
are the same sorts of machines only now
we've got two of them and they're
connected to our network so as Michael
mentioned we have to teach the network
how did you this routing so what happens
when we send a packet out of POD one
destined for pod for right same as
before it's going to leave the pod
that's going to enter the root namespace
we're going to hit the bridge now the
ARP is going to fail on that bridge
there's nobody on that bridge who's
answering this IP address so it's going
to send it out the default route the
default route in this case is each 0 so
we send it out the default route it
leaves the VM and it enters Google
clouds Network and it promptly goes to
nowhere
it goes nowhere because we have
anti-spoofing protection built into
Google Cloud and the network knows that
this VM has an IP address and the source
IP is not the right IP address so
we have to set up a couple of things
before we can make any of this work so
the first thing we do when we create a
VM we tell GCP that these are all
routers right and the routers have a
flag called can IP forward which means
that it's allowed to disable anti
schools protection but for only for this
VM the rest of the network is still
smooth safe then we add a single static
route per VM which says hey if you see
any packets bound for this IP range send
it over to this VM and the VM will know
what to do right the GCP Network handles
the rest so let's go back here we've got
this packet it's from pod 1 it's going
to pod 4 right this time it passes
through the network successfully and
it's delivered to the second VM and the
packet flows in the exact same way that
we looked at before there's nothing
special here there's no translations
required there's no encapsulation
there's no overlays it just flows the
way a network should flow so one other
thing that's important to remember we
just talked about network namespace
setup and ritual Ethernet device setup
and all of these areas and g-cloud to
turn off spoofing it's all automatically
handled for you in Google container
engine you don't have to go to the man
pages and learn all of these pieces you
just turn on the system and by default
as you start creating pods and creating
you know these things will just be set
up but let's get back to progressing
through the network stack inside of
Google container engine how do we deal
with change your cluster is a living
dynamic system sometimes you're going to
want to scale it up as load increases or
you're going to want to scale it down
possibly as you know load decreases or
you know maybe revenue becomes more of
an interesting issue in your life
rolling updates you're going to want to
turn off some pods and then turn them on
again with new software you're going to
want the pods maybe if they crash or
hang to be unscheduled and rescheduled
somewhere else maybe the VM is rebooting
all of these events involve your pod
getting a new IP address and keeping
track of all of these IP addresses it's
a lot of work and I have to start
keeping track of state and anyone who's
kept track of state knows that's never
fun so you want to find a way to have
your systems network traffic be able to
find the pods that you care about
without a lot of work on your behalf
Google container engine helps you with
this
with services some some done the service
abstraction it's an abstraction and
another resource or object that lives
inside the APS API server it's basically
a mapping of a cluster IP address or a
virtual IP address to a group of
endpoints usually pods it provides you a
stable VIP and the VIP when you send
traffic to it will then route that
traffic to the pods that are being
selectively associated with that service
we're going to examine the default
implementation of this in Google
container engine like many things in
Google container engine you can always
componentize it and try to do something
else that's really what you need the set
of the pods behind a service can change
dynamically and it doesn't really matter
as long as you have that VIP your
traffic can reach those pods so let's
try to create a service here's the camel
the fields that really matter is the
main in this case we're going to call it
the store - be4 baby all the store
back-end pods and the selector here says
the application that matches store and
the roles that are the backend so the
selector field here is going to then
find all of the pods that with these
labels and associate them with this
service what you get back is some
information from kubernetes api server
it's going to automatically create a
distributed load balancer for you and
it's also going to allocate this cluster
IP 10-9 376 and this is the IP address
that within the cluster any traffic to
that IP address is going to make sure it
reaches one of those pods and it's going
to smear this traffic over randomly and
fairly the idea here is that it's
balanced across all of those pots now
I'm going to take a slight digression
because this word is a very accurate
word in this context but it's overloaded
in networking and sometimes in
kubernetes the idea of what is an
endpoints resource or object in the API
server as we said earlier every time you
create a service you're also having to
select the pods that are associated with
that service so the traffic is going to
be routed to and you have a selector
associated with it well when you create
a service in Google container engine you
also have Google container engine for
you create an endpoints resource or
object with the same selector
so if you have a bunch of pods that you
associated with that service in this
case app store roll de well they're
going to be found by the endpoints of
the kubernetes system which will
associate them with the endpoints and
it's going to automatically create for
you
this endpoints object and why do we need
this well it turns out that in Google
container engine and in kubernetes in
general and open source also a lot of
objects and controllers really want to
know about all of the pods associated
with a service and they make this query
over and over and over again and it's an
expensive query so as an implementation
detail
we've decided in Google container engine
to create a resource just for this
mapping of service name to pod IP
addresses this way as pods come and go
we have a convenient cache of the
locations and IP addresses for all of
these pods it makes this kind of coming
in and out in out much like a pod going
up and down only thing that makes this
really interesting and sometimes
confusing is it has the name endpoints
and we have HTTP endpoints and we have a
lot of other networks terms that refer
to endpoints that's the only reason we
brought it up today it confused me it
took me like two months to realize
exactly what we were talking about one
started project let's take a look now at
a life of a packet from the pod to a
service looks very familiar what we've
seen before the EPAct leaves the pod and
should I move or just good ok the packet
leaves the pod source IP address is a
pod and what's different now is the
destination IP address is going to the
service this case service 1 goes from
the network namespace through the pipe
it's the bridge but instead of going to
another pod it's going to instead go to
IP tables in IP tables we're going to do
a d-mat and the d-mat is going to take
that destination service remember
service is just a handle to a group of
pods it's going to take that service and
pick the pod that we want this packet to
go to in this case pod 99 and it's going
to use a system called contract to
remember which pod it sent this I teach
conditioned ection of traffic to
contract contract is another Linux
system that does connection cracking for
you it bases it on the five tuple of IP
header that you're sending the traffic
out to and it does a lot of other things
too but it's going to remember where it
came from or where the initial
destination was we're going to see how
it's being used for kubernetes
networking as we continue to talk so now
we have rewritten the definition IP
address for pod 99 or IP tables has done
the load balancing on this machine to
take our traffic instead of to the
service IP to the actual pod that the
service is fronting for us and then when
that pot is responded it comes back
coming from pod 99 saying I want to go
back on one its IP tables the IP tables
use it on crack users contract to on the
at the packet rewrites the source IP
header from two circuits one and sorry
we haven't some audio stuff going on it
is cool okay I'll continue and then it
goes on its merry way just like we've
described a few times already all the
way back to the pod ones network
namespace so let's take a little bit a
little more look at the IP tables the IB
table rules if you look at them raw are
really really scary but this is some of
the things you really have to remember
when you look at services and IP tables
the IP tables are really performing one
piece of logic they're trying to route
that package in the traffic in general
to the pods behind the service so they
check to see the destination IP and the
port match the services import and if
they do they're going to pick one of the
backends at random and then rewrite the
destination and send that connection on
its way to that appropriate pod now
here's something else that's kind of
funny and a lot of people last about all
of this work is happening within the
Linux kernel we are not copying the data
out of the kernel into user space
playing with the packets and then
sending it back into user space again
it's really inefficient it's really not
the right way
do it but it is the way when we first
began working on the Google container
engine it is how things used to work and
this is just sort of getting things off
the ground and prototyping so because of
that the system and that the pod that
actually maintains all of these IP table
rules is called the cube proxy because
it used to be a proxy for all this
network traffic it's not actually a
proxy today all it does is just talk
into it can I sing in dance
all right great I don't know can you
know I can't sing nor can i dent thank
you Tim my pleasure
so cube proxy cube proxy is a deposit
lives on every node and it maintains
these IP table rules for you it used to
do this in userspace
which is why it has a name that's very
confusing but now it just maintains the
IP table rules that keep the services
running it's a controller just like many
of the other pieces of kubernetes
infrastructure and it watches the API
for services changes and when they
change it's going to update the IP
tables for you so let's go take a look
at life of a packet from pod to service
right now the source is going to come to
the service and destination is coming to
a pod destination is coming to the
Potter
oh wait I'm at the wrong button between
the mic and the singing it's way too
much fun services DMS is just another
service inside of Google container
engine that's how we implemented it you
don't really want a hard code the name
and IP if you want a hard code the IP
address of all of these services into
your code but if you know the name of
the service you may want a hard code the
name of the service to direct your
traffic to all of the pods associated
with that service so Google container
engine will automatically when you
create that service put the services
name inside the D on that space inside
the Google container engine it uses
normal a and servi records so you don't
have to do anything and DNS itself runs
as a pod and as a service for you just
using the same infrastructure that we're
asking people to use
DNS service is got a little bit of extra
magic and sugar just like other services
things that we can show you any service
and we use this for DNS can request a
particular cluster IP so we know with
DNS we want to use the IP address 1000
10 so we specify that when we create the
service and we know that we're going to
get that IP address we'll get an error
when we create the service also
something special about DNS is its auto
scale to the cluster size it's actually
a ratio of nodes versus cores but the
idea here is we don't really ever want
DNS to be overloaded the Google
container engine has a little bit more
surprised in fun and adventure when we
do that so we Auto scale it to keep
things running correctly again just like
other services the VIP is stable
services are simple and powerful you can
use any port you want you're not too
worried about conflicts you you know can
request a particular cluster IP as we
just described and you can remap port
that's all there really is to it the big
thing to remember again is services are
an abstraction they're an idea of
mapping of a name and IP address to pods
that lives and you can manage in the API
server but the implementation of it it's
kind of spread across all the IP tables
and maintained by cube proxy inside of
Google container engine it doesn't only
have one running process that's doing
all of this work but all you need to
know as a customer and a client is you
set up the service you hit the client IP
address or you hit that DNS name and
that's really all you have to handle
Google container engine takes care of
all this complexity for you let's talk
about sending external traffic what if
you want to take traffic outside of your
GCP project to the outside world
egress VM all get private IPS inside the
1000 / 8 IP range and VMs can also get
public IPS when they get a public IP
they get one public IP maps to one
private IP so let's look at the life of
a packet from going from VM to the
Internet here we have our same happy
virtual machine with the root namespace
each zero device inside a DCP project we
send a packet out with the VM internals
IP address the source going to a date
eight and then in the NAT subsystem of
the DCP project we rewrite the internal
address to the external so the external
internet knows where this packet came
from and can route it back and away we
go
and then because a t-888 maintained by
this fabulously happy company comes back
really fast and we go back to the vm
external address bot so for those of you
are not in the audience there's one
person laughing at my jokes which is
really cool we rewrite the external IP
address to the internal IP address not
really a big deal it's normal routing
like always what happens with a pod
everything's a little different just
like always the pod comes from the
namespace comes up to the device hits
the bridge comes out to the VM the
source here sorry I went over that the
source here is the pod IP address hits
the mat and it's dropped the one-to-one
mat inside the GCP for security only
really understands and allows the MIT to
get out the pod IP does not equal to VM
IP so it gets dropped
when in doubt what's the answer IP
tables and so here we masquerade again
or use source mat and we apply this to
any packet that a destination that's
outside of the internal clusters IP
range so let's take a quick look at that
again license packet pod to internet we
go all the way up to the IP tables we
rewrite the pod one source to the VM
internal IP address it leaves the VM it
goes to the mat subsystem now we rewrite
it again from VM internal to external
just as before goes to eight eight eight
eight comes right back we rewrite the
destination external to internal jf as
before hits the ethernet device goes
into the IP tables we use contract in
the same system that we built all this
logic on to now we write it with the pod
ones IP address and by now I hope some
of you are tired of this path
as we go back to the pod one network
namespace so that gives you a pretty
good picture of how packets move around
within your GCP cluster right and that
was super cool but it's not really that
interesting because most of us have to
deal with the outside world and getting
out to you know github is cool and all
but it's not going to sell you product
you got to take traffic in right this is
a really complicated problem for
kubernetes in general we have to build
it to the particular platforms that
you're running on so coo Brandis on GCP
is going to rely on a couple of
different GCP products to bring traffic
into the cluster and we're going to see
how we use those products
so in particular we for the kubernetes
api where we set a type load balancer
we're going to use Google's network load
balancer at l4 and when we use the
ingress resource we're going to use the
l7 load balancer the HTTP and HTTPS load
balancer so let's look at l4 first
because it's the less exciting one so we
looked at service earlier right Michael
mentioned cluster IPS so we're going to
change the type from a cluster IP to a
load balancer now the way we've set this
up is these are sort of concentric so
cluster IP node port load balancers so
load balancer is still is a cluster IP
it's still going to get allocated Nyepi
address within my cluster but what
happens when I set this is another
controller wakes up this is our Google
Cloud Controller it wakes up and it says
hey I know what to do with that I'm
going to go off and I'm going to create
a Google load balancer and I'm going to
set up all the routing and I'm going to
make it work for you so when it's done
with that it's going to write back to
the service you have a load balancer and
it's ingress point is this IP address
right so now you as an end user you can
take that IP address you can stick it in
your DNS you can share it with your
customers you can write it on the
bathroom wall
people will find your store so let's
look at how this works like in practice
so we have a cluster here and to make
things fun this cluster has three VMs
one VM happens to have one of my
particular pod one VM has none
and one VM has two so now I create that
service with type of load balancer this
controller wakes up and it goes off and
it creates a Google Network load
balancer if anybody's really familiar
with the Google cloud API this is a
forwarding rule right it's going to
create a forwarding rule and it's going
to point that forwarding rule at all of
my VMs and this means we don't ever have
to update the forwarding rule except if
the VM change because that's sort of a
slow API so we program it in program to
all of these VMs so now user found our
store and they're going to send us in
traffic the packet here is from the
client to the load balancer this is
important now we go through this load
balancer the load balancer has to make a
decision it looks at all of the VMs that
are eligible to be chosen it's going to
pick one of these three in this case
we're going to pick VM one it doesn't
really matter which one we choose
because the same flow is going to happen
in all of them so now we send the packet
on a shoot we have a firewall all right
so the first thing we're going to do
automatically is we're going to run
g-cloud firewalls create we're going to
open up the firewall for you on that
port so that the load balancer can now
talk to your service so now if this
packet comes through this firewall or
comes through the load balancer and it
enters your GCT network this is the
coolest part Google's network load
balancer is not a proxy it's a packet
forwarder so when this packet comes into
your network the destination address is
still the load balancer and the clients
of the source address is still the
original client so you can examine that
IP packet and figure out who sent you
this traffic right that's pretty neat
and it's really important and I'm going
to mess it up in just a second so this
packet arrived at a VM and we bring it
into this VM the Patt the source and
destinations are unchanged from before
now hold on a second I said says it
doesn't matter which VM you land on
right but clearly one of these VMs would
be a bad choice right the load balancer
like all of the cloud load balancers as
we go through this container revolution
they only know about VM right VM don't
map one to one with pods we have more
more positively do VM so we have less
pausing we do VM
or we have the same number but they just
don't happen to map correctly we call
this the imbalance problem right imagine
for a minute that I actually set it up
so that it only sent traffic to these
two VM and we ignored the one that has
no backends right I'm going to send 50%
of the traffic here I'm going to send
50% of my traffic here that seems
completely reasonable from the load
balancers point of view since it doesn't
know that there's more BMS on one than
on the other so at the end which you get
is one pod that has 50% of your traffic
and two pods that have 25% of your
traffic whatever monitoring system
you're going to use is going to go nuts
right it's not going to know what to do
with this it's not going to know how to
scale your application and your office
team is going to hate you I mean they
probably already do but they'll hate you
more so this is the general imbalance
problem so we set out with the initial
design to not trigger the imbalance
problem so how do we avoid the imbalance
we squirt some IP tables on to it
IP tables is the the caulk of networking
systems you squirt it in wherever
there's a gap to fill in and smooth
things over so this packet comes into
this VM and we're going to consider
which pod am I going to send it to right
this is the same path that we saw before
only now it's coming in from outside and
we have to consider all of the pods
across all of the VM right so in this
case we're going to choose
pathologically and we're going to pick a
pot on a different VM right so I'm going
to send this packet first of all first
one to do a destination at which we saw
before this is literally the same set of
IP tables rule so don't think of these
things as additive they are really the
same set of logic I'm going to do my
destination app I'm going to send the
packet out now note the quantity address
here has changed the destination it says
pod 2 but the original is still the
client via the source IP and I'm going
to forward this packet down and it's
going to land at the second VM and just
like before it's going to arrive at this
pod we're going to store going to
respond we're sending back from pod 2 to
our client and because it's from pod 2
to the client it's going to go out to
the Internet it actually will go through
the NAT thing that Michael just talked
about but it's going to go out to the
client and it's going to get dropped why
does it get dropped well the client sent
a packet to the load balancer
it didn't send a packet to this pod or
this VM and so the TCP session isn't
going to complete right so let's rewind
for a minute
back to when that packet first arrived
at the first VM we have to do a second
map which is the source NAT we have to
change the source IP to be from this VM
I'm forcing you the first VM to be in
the traffic path in order to achieve my
balancing so now when you see this
packet fly across the network the source
is VM 1 and the destination is pot 2 all
that cool stuff about keeping the client
IP address from the network load
balancer I just frittered away but just
wait there's more so there's more IP
tables the packets going to arrive at
the second VM in the same way we saw
before it's going to be delivered to the
pod it's going to come back no problem
contract is going to wake up realize
that it has to unmask this packet twice
and then it's going to respond back up
the load balancer will return it and it
will merrily go on its way to your
customer that is a little complicated so
that imbalance problem it's a it's a
real problem and we chose to avoid it
right now the good news is that in
practice were really well balanced the
bad news is you have that next trick hop
which can cause some extra network
latency and it hides the client from the
users back-end it turns out surprise
users want to make this choice for
themselves so don't dump them how do you
deal with this network problem only
local not just IP tables we're going to
apply an annotation one of the problems
that we're trying to resolve here well
sometimes some of the customers was
consent they would rather risk the
imbalance or find a way to provision
around the imbalance and they really
care about getting the client IP address
they know it's a big deal and also they
don't want to deal with the double hop
and the latency issues so in Google
containers engine we now support only
local you can apply the annotation only
local onto the service
and we're going to go see how that works
to again this is all being set up for
you Auto magically what only local does
is it's going to make sure that when you
make that routing selection the VM that
you pick is the local one
so as Tim said earlier the imbalance
here is across VMs we're balanced okay
we are going to have a BM one versus the
m3 is where the pods live we have a
health check to let us know not to go to
the m2 but when you go and check out the
pods below that we can end up with this
imbalance if we have a lot more pods
than nodes
this isn't that really that big an issue
it's just sort of noise for the
imbalance to give a thousand pods and
let's say only four nodes it doesn't
really matter if you have many many more
not nodes and pods well all of those
pods are going to be single things on
the nodes or the VMS and so you're not
going to have an imbalance either
between the health checks you're always
going to have a nice distribution at
that first level where the network load
balancer is doing the balancing to VM
get into problems when you have
situations like this where the number of
pods and the number of nodes are about
the same and then the level of like Tim
said you can have some issues where the
the load that your pods are dealing with
are not going to be uniform so with only
local on traffic's comes in as we said
earlier the health check is not going to
consider VM to source IP addresses the
client destination is the load balancer
we can choose vm 1 vm 3 we're going to
pick vm 3 because it's more fun and
interesting vm 1 also fun maybe not as
much interesting we go to VM 3 source
client destination OB and then when we
get on VM 3 we hit the IP tables and
remember the IP tables could send you to
anywhere that's going to have that pod
but in this case with only local it is
only going to send you to a pod that is
local to this VM it's only going to
consider pod 2 and pod 3 clearly marked
in green bright emerald click green it
goes to pod two it easily could have
gone to pod 3 but we just chose pod 2
for this session
these the d nach reaches pod 2 and then
goes back through the same matting and
contracting an IP table impasse that
we've discussed over and over again
during this talk comes all the way back
out to the node load balancer and then
back to the client and as a result
what's really important here is that
your pod the code that your developers
wrote or maybe you wrote is going to be
able to see the client's IP address
you're not going to play these games of
not knowing where the packet came from
you get the normal expected path that
makes the most sense
ingress right oh so now you all have
internalized exactly how kubernetes
works at layer 4 so let's talk about
layer 7 because that's way more
interesting right there's been a couple
of really good talks here this week
about the cool stuff that's happening in
the layer 7 space to bring up layer 7 we
have a different kind of resource in
kubernetes called an ingress ingress is
built on top of services so ingress the
first thing you need to do is change
your service to a node port now you
could use remember I said earlier you've
cluster IP node port load balancer you
could use load balancer if you want an
elf 4 also but generally people will say
I only want the l7 so I set up as type
node port what node port does is it
tells kubernetes allocate me a port the
same port on every VM in my cluster and
make sure that that port forwards onto
my service how do we forward onto that
service everybody iptables so it's again
literally it's the same exact code path
that we followed before so you declare
this thing as a type of node port and
then you introduce an ingress object the
ingress object represents a higher level
concept it's an l7 HTTP load balancer
and the cool thing about HTTP load
balancers is they have an understanding
of what you're actually doing at the
application level so things like a URL
can map to a different service so in
this case you can see like the world's
simplest ingress has a flash customers
URL and
that customers URL is going to go to our
customers back-end and the splash
product URL is going to go to our
products back-end right each of these
two backends are different services
which are backed by a set of pods
through this selector mechanism that
we've been seeing over and over again so
you can see here sorry I just
highlighted that so again just like a
service when the when you do this the
controller wakes up the controller goes
out to Google Cloud and it programs the
HTTP load balancer again if anybody's
familiar with the Google cloud API the
HTTP load balancer is actually about
eight resources to the Google cloud API
it's sort of complicated to set up
because it's so incredibly powerful we
take that for you we do it all for you
we configure the instance groups and the
backends and the forwarding rules and
the target proxies we set it all up and
in the end we point your IP address here
again you can take this IP address you
can put it in your DNS and off to the
races so let's take a look at some
traffic again so we've got our cluster
we've got our blue our green services
our customers and our products these
ports exist on every node so when you
create that that service or the ingress
object we're going to go off and create
the Google cloud load balancer Google
cloud load balancer as before we teach
it about all three VM and through the
through the instance group mechanism and
we start taking our traffic so costs are
a client send something to our load
balancer on the flash products path
that's the green one we're going to take
the packets through and again the load
balancer has to choose which VM I going
to send this to it's going to look at
all the information that it has
available to it and it's going to choose
a VM in this case it's going to choose
VM three I said that we're looking at
the green service so again I chose three
to sort of be pessimal it's going to
send this traffic off to the VM now take
note here of the IP addresses the source
here is the load balancer but it's not
actually the IP address is a load
balancer that you had it's sort of a
Google internal address that we use for
all of our load balancing pool we
publish Doc's on these this range that
we use for our load balancers
this is because our HTTP load balancer
is a full proxy right it will terminate
your TCP session so you could do things
like SSL where you give us your
certificate will terminate the SSL and
we'll pass the pack on to the back what
it means is you lose that client IP
again but you don't actually lose it
because this is HTTP and HTTPS so cool
because it's got things like headers so
the client IP address will be stuck in
that x-forwarded-for header which you
can then use if any piece of your stack
understands HTTP you can pull that out
and log that correctly so now the packet
is destined for vm3 now so we've changed
both the source and the destination if
we go back you see the packet here
clients to load balancer here it's load
balancer to VM this packet is going to
arrive at the green port and this is
important because we use the receipt at
that green port as a trigger to say hey
I know what to do with this this is a
service and I'm going to send it off
shoot I'm gonna send it to IP tables
again same thing we've seen six times
now IP tables is going to choose a pod
it's going to do that that that we saw
before it's going to bounce out of the
machine it's going to fly over our
network we're going to receive it no
tricks this time it's actually going to
work and it's going to come back now we
receive it in IP tables we do the
opposite of that contract that we saw
before and we send the packet back on
and we have a happy customer so it's
even more complicated than l4 and it
suffers some of the same problems you've
got this double hop still right so it
turns out customers still want to make
this decision for themselves so we don't
have to worry about losing the clients
IP address but as Jim just said the
double hop is you know still a problem
and it adds that complexity everyone
here can see this slide it looks very
similar to the other only local slide
for a service you can have inside of
ingress these sort of sub services based
on the path or the annotations that
you want and you can specify only local
again you can configure the sub service
beside the ingress is only local and you
risk the imbalance as before which can
usually be avoided by how you choose to
apportion out your nodes and pods and
remove the second hop so there's a lot
more that we could discuss I mean I can
just read from the slide pod liveness
probe graceful termination cloud health
checks firewalls and so on and so forth
but networking is really deep the
functionality and features that people
want out of Google container engine for
networking the list goes on and on and
on and on and on instead of talking
about each one of these subtopics you
know we really wanted to make sure that
people understood the routing basics
both in out of the intra cluster inter
cluster egress and ingress and that's
sort of what we're hoping to do here I
know that there's got a little
repetitious but it's because we build
and don't waste the functionality and
infrastructure that we have inside of
Google container engine can I and I add
I spent the week here working downstairs
at the meet the expert table and I've
spoken to I know some of you I have
wanted to pull these slides out at least
a dozen times over the last two days to
explain concepts and so I thought it was
really important that we get this
information out there I get the sense
from a lot of people that this is
complicated that they don't understand
it it's an interesting talk because by
the end you get a lot of okay we've got
it we've got it you reinforced it but
then before the talk a lot of people
want to know exactly about this sort of
topic and so even instead of Google when
we wrote this talk it's gotten a lot of
interest watch this space Google
container engine is definitely a moving
target there's the open source
components and the open source
architecture which is being worked on by
you know companies and engineers all
over the world and you know lots of
regard to texture and lots of just bug
fixes and elegant sand simplifications
and development work is being gone
undergone even as we speak even Google
we were working on the Google container
engine part as we host it and integrated
with the GCT environment so next 18 it's
going to look different it will be
looking maybe faster maybe less iptables
for some of the problems that we just
elaborated on probably
more iptables for new functionality and
new features and different ways to
approach these problems so they'll
definitely be more ins and outs and we
hope that you come back to learn more
about it next year if you want to know
more about what's going on and not wait
till next year because you know who
wants to wait here's our website for
documentation you can look at the code
right now and start playing with it and
examining how things work in detail if
you wanted to ask questions there's our
chat and here's our Twitter there's also
a code lab downstairs which we've been
told not enough people know about so
please feel free to get your hands dirty
it's really the best way to learn about
anything and there are people that are
willing to help you get started finally
thank you
[Music]
you